Satoru Gojo, without any doubt, is one of
the coolest anime characters every created.
And yet, what makes his character so intriguing
is not his unimaginable power or his fantastic
sense of humor, but the tragic irony that
lies beneath them. Who then is Satoru Gojo?
What does it mean to be the strongest?
What is actually going on behind those
cold and clear eyes? And why does he
cover them? It's time to find out.
Gojo is one of the most influential characters in
JuJutsu Kaisen. And I mean, being the strongest
curse user out there, how could he not be.
The biggest strength Akutami has as an author,
is that he takes a lot of inspiration from other
Shounen stories, combines and expands upon them
and ultimately makes them even more intriguing
and fascinating as they already were. Satoru Gojo
is no exception. Many traits of his can quite
easily be traced back to other characters,
but in the end he emerges as one of the most
unique and complex personalities out there.
If you had to pick one word to describe
Satoru Gojo, I believe there is no doubt
that 'Strength' is the only fit.
Gojo is the pinnacle of the JuJutsu
world. If you need any proof, he is to
curses what Sukuna is to the Sorcerers:
An unbeatable force of nature that can only
be sealed and not actually killed. To fully
understand the tragedy of his character, you have
to understand what strength means for Gojo and
how it dominates every aspect of his
life as well as his role in the story.
Being the strongest character in the story, he
serves as a sign-post to both the audience and the
protagonists, what is actually possible in this
world, and how far behind they actually still are.
Gojo's fighting style and the respect and fear
he enjoys from both friends and foes alike
is something we know from many other stories.
Netero in Hunter x Hunter,Shanks in One Piece,
Shanks in Fairy Tail or All Might in Boku no Hero.
Like all of them, Gojo has a very
easy-going, boyish sort of personality,
that is immediately replaced by pure strength
and authority when his patience is tested.
He is the the sort of character that almost
single-handedly holds the balance in the world,
and the moment they are removed, chaos
erupts. While personality and look wise,
Gojo could be considered a cooler and
more entertaining version of Kakashi,
as a teacher, he comes closer to All Might, in
that he is not exactly the best at teaching, but
good and thoughtful enough to grow the
next generation of the "good guys". In
fact Gojo has quite a bunch of wonderful, if
admittedly unconventional teaching moments.
And while they typical mentor-types usually
feel like their best days are already over,
Gojo very much seems to be in his absolute
prime when we meet him in the story.
Akutami makes it very clear very early on,
what Gojo is capable of. Building on sharp
reflexes and a bright tactical intellect,
his ridiculous amount of cursed energy and
physical strength as well as his capability
to perform a complete domain expansion are only
the tip of the ice berg. Gojo has been blessed,
not only with one, but TWO inherited abilities,
that in combination make him more god than man.
The first of these is 'limitless', an ability that
allows Gojo to freely manipulate space and matter
down to an atomic level. This allows him
to slow down movement and decide what can
or cannot touch him. We se this explained in
his fight with Jogo in the most hilarious way.
However Gojo is also able to
attract and repulse matter,
giving him gravity and anti-gravity attributes
alike. Finally, one of his most destructive
skills is combining both of these attributes,
which results in the complete annihilation
of any matter caught within the attack.
As if this wasn't scary enough however,
Gojo also has inherited the Six Eyes, an
ability that we still know very little about.
We know however, that it allows him
to perceive the world around him
in terms of mass, cursed energy and so on and so
forth, making it the perfect fit for Limitless.
The workings of these abilities are
actually incredibly cleverly crafted, but
not related to the point of this video. Let me
know if you would like to learn more about that.
The main takeaway point here, is that Gojo has had
the one thing values most in the world of JuJutsu,
raw, unmatched power that allows him to shape
the world around him in whatever way he pleases.
And this is what brings us into the deeply nested
and layered realm of Satoru Gojo's personality.
Due to his innate strength and claim to authority,
Gojo understandably is extremely confident in his
abilities, to the point where he believes himself
to be invincible. In relation to the central moral
argument of JuJutsu Kaisen - what constitutes
a good life - his view is quite different
from Itadori's. While Itadori thinks that a good
life means enabling others to have a good death,
for Gojo, the answer is strength. In essence: When
you have strength you have agency over the world,
your own life and that of others. Thus, while Yuji
expresses his believe in his hero complex, trying
to save anyone waker than him and caring way to
much about others, Gojo is very self-centered and,
as we will see, has difficulties understanding
and caring for people weaker than him. He even
tells Megumi to become stronger himself
and less reliant on others. (Greedy)
And yet, despite their polar
views on life, surprisingly,
in the end Gojo and Itadori have one of the best
relationships in the show. On the surface, this
seems to be due to their similarly extroverted
and genuinely funny personalities. But the
truth is, that both Yuuji and Gojo try to get
rid of their loneliness. However, but their god
and hero complex keep them from truly creating any
meaningful and mutual relationships with others,
as they can't let themselves be vulnerable by
letting anyone come close enough to help them
in return. As Gojo formulates it: Yuji and he
always go for the home run. In that way, while
expressed in different ways, both Yuji and Gojo
share the same fundamental weakness: Loneliness.
To understand Gojo's sense of Loneliness, we
have to understand that despite his sense of
superiority, luckily for everyone around him,
he actually has a strong sense of morality.
Gojo cares about the well-being of humanity and
and even more so for the people close to him.
The society of JuJutsu sorcerers in their
preside to fight the curses that threaten
humanity and human life have ironically
enough morphed into an environment that is
incredibly de-humanizing in of itself. All
that matters are blood-lines, influence and
yes, strength. Despite being blessed with the
most desired trait amongst the sorcerers, or
maybe exactly because of it, Gojo knows very
well how corrupted this society has become.
His big desire and rive therefore is not to
eradicate all curses or something similar,
but is pointed inwards and aims at revolutionizing
the system of the JuJutsu world itself.
A very intriguing desire for him to have,
because it can't be solved by strength alone,
but requires the one thing Gojo isn't great
at: Human relationships and comrades with a
common ideology. Gojou knows this. He doesn’t
want to be the strongest forever. In fact he
wants to be surpassed. However, the major flaw
in Gojou’s thinking is that he can't help but
resemble the system he was born and raised
in. NO matter how hard he tries to struggle,
he’s still a part of the system
he’s desperately trying to reform.
And so the real struggle Gojo faces is that
despite his self-centeredness and his god complex,
deep down this man has a quite big heart
and sense of morality, that in the end makes
him vulnerable to losses. Hanami and Jogo got
away because he prioritized Yuji's safety over
catching them and in general prioritizing Yuji's
education over winning which was why he was there
in the first place. Mahito was able to steal the
cursed objects from the school because he worried
and prioritized the lives of his students because
he determined the true loss would be their deaths.
And so, based on his emotional
and compassionate side,
the reason Gojo feels so incredibly lonely and
isolated is ironically enough his own strength
and power. And this is represented by
the key symbol of Gojou’s character:
his eyes. The reason he wears sunglasses like
a blind man, and then a literal blindfold later
on is due to the fact that he is always staring
into the infinity. He always sees everything.
He’s literally so good at seeng through
people, at reading them, that they don’t
look like individual people to him. Every single
person on earth has a rich internal world filled
with their own thoughts, emotions and biases. But
Gojou doesn’t perceive that. He only sees matter,
cursed energy, speed and so on and so forth.
Gojou has always distanced himself both from his
own feelings and the feelings of others. It’s
understandable considering the divide between
Gojou and other people in the first place.
As a result, it’s really hard for him to see
other people as real people. To him they appear
like mere characters all reading off of a script.
As a result Gojo has always been distanced form
his own feelings and the feeling s of others.
This distance shines through
in various ways. Notice it’s
always Gojo making the pop cultural references.
He was the one who taught Itadori to handle his
emotions and cursed energy by literally making him
sit down and watch movie after movie. And while I
strongly belief that stories are done of the mots
powerful tools we as humans possess, having
feelings about fictional characters is nonetheless
not quite the same as having feelings for
a real person. Because instead of feeling
with people you are the silent observer on the
sideline. Granted the ability to see everything,
life became more of a movie than reality, with
Gojo being the only one in the theater. Or,
as the master himself would phrase it: "When
granted everything, you can't do anything ..."
Thus Gojo literally has to blind himself in order
to perceive other humans as actual people. And
I think it's fair to call that quite tragic.
However, it also shows us once again that Gojo
cares. He cares that he can't see people. He cares
that he feels alone. And he cares that people
suffer under the current system. And yet he's
the strongest. Thus, Gojou is stripped down to